20 tale winners all under age 21
$100,000 to drop out of school and
pursue our dreams this is team
Technorati
what do you have - just checking out the
tech shop website my name is Sean - no
Bala I'm 19 years old and I'm working on
creating a new computer interfaces that
use your sense of touch to communicate
information rather than your site or
your sense of here so it's supposed to
be like a like a community workshop
where you kind of have access to a bunch
of really expensive equipment Wow it's
like a hack a space for hardware as soon
as I landed I was really excited about
checking out the tech shop in San
Francisco it has a certain amount of
history just in the startup culture the
biggest challenge for my ideas is going
to be making hardware that's stable and
usable hardware's just a lot more
challenging than software in the sense
that it has a really long life cycle
before you get to something that's
usable and workable
well welcome to tech shop please do wear
the super safety goggles in truth and
justice
these are the tools that basically made
the Industrial Revolution happen so this
is a manual mouth I joked that it's very
much like operating an etch-a-sketch
we've had people make parts for lunar
landers Navy SEAL diving equipment it's
crazy we have like art history
professors and like surfers and all
kinds of people who are generally not in
the realms of engineering like playing
with these machines we have people
making satellites and samurai armor now
this now this is a cool machine say this
little stream of sand and water that
comes out 2.0 four inches in diameter
and that stream of water will cut
through six inches of plate steel so is
this programmable yeah actually really
easy to draw for this machine so if you
wanted to make like a bunch of like
small things in bulk you do this cut
like a giant piece of okay okay so this
is the second floor of tech shop San
Francisco you can see it's more of a
design quiet programming place these
tables are really special because
there's nowhere else that you get twelve
year old kids sitting next to venture
capitalists and like astronauts
obviously 3d printing is very prominent
right now and you can see some of the
prints right here so what's like the
minimum width you know I haven't had to
look it up because this is probably made
on the new machine and I haven't even
SPECT it out yet yeah I mean they're
definitely showing off how thin like the
printing kinga
this is your brand-new detect shop
magnet printing machine we just got this
at this location basically what it does
is a takes in the opinion magnet cooks
it's all the particles are just floating
and then it prints it aligns them and
cools it okay I could actually there's
like you can create like a textile
surface called bubble wrap so you can
actually say like this bag and actually
create like a like an electronic like
textured surface on the bag where like
different parts of it pop up and down
could you invert that and make it so
that if I'm wearing a suit and I'm
stroking myself somebody else could feel
that
yeah that's dude that's pretty cool tech
shop right now the future is really
uncertain and the main thing that I want
to focus on is is really learning how to
do really cool things with with hardware
and learning how to build things what
was your initial kind of inspiration to
go in this route it started up as a
research project to see whether you can
construct EGIS almost like a like an
augmented reality interface for someone
who is disabled whether
an auditory disability or visual
disability that's pretty cool man when I
was 5 years old I wanted to be an
astronaut so this is a very different
career trajectory if I followed my
five-year-old goals looking backwards it
feels like like goals have slowly and
slowly become more and more tangible so
I start to think less about a really big
picture of like I want to go to the moon
and more over like what should I be
doing the next couple weeks that can be
like really awesome to play with or
really awesome as a learning experience
tune in for the next episode of teen
technorati when Catherine Wow's us with
her many talents
and be sure to subscribe to the wired
Channel